foreign
one of the questions was why do brains
sleep and dream sleep is still a little
complicated but you know the bunch of
hypotheses but I think that my student
and I solved why we dream at night
and I can tell you if you're interested
in that of course no thanks yeah we're
in a rush here yeah please please go
ahead David it has to do with brain
plasticity so the brain is always
reconfiguring itself it's a very dynamic
system
and you know every one of these neurons
in your head would they look like you
know branching trees and they make 10
000 connections to other neurons these
are constantly moving so imagine like
moving trees that are plugging and
unplugging and seeking and connecting
with others and so on so anyway that's
called brain plasticity this constant
reconfiguration and it turns out the
surprise in Neuroscience is how rapidly
things can start moving and changing and
so some colleagues of mine at Harvard
back in
I think 2007
did this experiment where they put
people in in fmri the brain scanner and
they blindfolded them tightly and they
were doing things like you know when
you're exposed to sound or touch what is
that you know what's happening in the
brain and what they found is that in 60
minutes
the visual system started responding to
touch and to sound and that was really
unexpected because we know that if you
go blind your visual system will get
taken over
especially as if you're really young but
no one would have ever dreamed that
you'd start seeing the first signs of
Takeover in 60 minutes and so that got
my student and I to start thinking about
something right away and we realized
that dreaming has to do with the
rotation of the planet and this is
because
you know the planet rotates Into
Darkness so we spend half our time in
the dark obviously I'm not talking about
electricity blessed times but historical
evolutionary times
what this means is
you can still hear and smell and taste
and touch in the dark but you can't see
in the dark and that puts the visual
system at a disadvantage it's like you
have been blindfolded in a sense and so
what we realized is
the visual system has to fight back to
to keep its territory all during the
night and so that's what dreaming is
about every 90 minutes you've got these
very specialized circuits that blast
activity just into the visual cortex
that's all that happens in dreaming is
it's going just to primary visual cortex
all this random activity
and it's just to keep it defended
against takeover from its neighbors to
prevent the weeds of other senses from
encroaching on the Walled Garden of
vision exactly you got it you got it
it's a screensaver
what's very interesting is a lot of
people have asked me when I present this
I'm presenting this at a big talk at
Stanford tomorrow by the way you know a
lot of people say like wait don't we
already know why we dream and the answer
is no we don't know a dream there are
various hypotheses but that doesn't mean
you stop making hypotheses and the
reason this one matters I think is
because it is the first ever one that
makes quantitative predictions across
species so what we did is we
found 25 different species of primates
and we looked at how plastic their
brains are some primates come out very
plastic like Homo sapiens others like
the gray mouse lemur it's called is you
know very not plastic it drops out it
reaches puberty rapidly it knows how to
walk rapidly it it's just it's it's sort
of pre-programmed if you want to think
about it that way what are you using as
a proxy or a measurement for plasticity
it's time to wean from their mothers
time to walking time to puberty things
like this I got it so how much is kind
of out of the box versus how much is
molding of the Play-Doh you got it
that's exactly it and so homo sapiens
it's unbelievable I mean we're so
useless for so long and that's because
we've got these extraordinary plastic
Brands we drop into the world Half Baked
and we absorb the world around us we
absorb the language and the culture and
all the knowledge that has come before
us and that's why it takes us so long to
develop but you know these are some some
of the other monkeys and apes or
whatever drop out they're good to go and
if you look at something like an
alligator you know it's just like eat
run mate that's all it's doing there's
no there's nothing other than the
pre-programming that it needs okay so
anyway it turns out if you look at the
amount of REM sleep rapid eye movement
sleep rapid eye movement sleep is what
correlates with dreaming if you look at
the amount of REM sleep that these
different animals get you find that it
correlates perfectly like a
perfect machine gun correlation Samora
REM more plasticity exactly by the way
if you're a baby human you dream all the
time they have about 50 percent of their
sleep is REM sleep it's dream sleep
and as you get older your brain is less
plastic and by the way you have less
percentage of REM sleep but anyway for a
an animal that's not particularly
plastic it has very little dream sleep
are you aware of any
counter examples are there any species
that seem to exhibit
a decent percentage of REM sleep but
that one would not conclude are
particularly
High plasticity outside of primates no
no I don't know any counter examples
where they have a lot of REM sleep but I
did come across one which I thought was
a real problem for the hypothesis which
is elephants elephants have almost no
REM sleep they do have a little bit of
REM once in a while but otherwise they
don't and of course you know elephants
have big brains and so on but it turns
out elephants only sleep one to two
hours a night and they have excellent
night vision so they don't need to keep
their visual cortex
protected against Takeover in the same
way that we do
so that actually falls right into line
in the theory that's fascinating